[Music]
and we are
hopefully back uh apologies for this uh
minor
interruption and we uh move on to
uh the nimzo which has progressed
towards a very sharp position which
uh as will be the norm on this show
vladimir knows something about it and i
really really don't
well i i know i i don't know uh much
about it i mean i know that i've
analyzed it that i remember very well it
was
extremely sharp and uh prob leading to a
very unclear position
pretty equal if i remember well but i
cannot really i remember
there was a peace sacrifice at some
point
but yes that's all i can say now i mean
i cannot really
uh tell you what was the exact
continuation
uh at some point black was trying to
take edc d
uh at some point this is my first
question well here of course queen takes
defines
yeah exactly if you wanted to include
egcd you were supposed to do it here
right because
i think in this position you are forcing
more or less forcing cd
yeah and now with the inclusion of
knight h5 and bishop e3 which is what
they played in the game
you just lose on the sport i think if
you take the pawn on g5 because 25
attacks absolutely everything
yeah well that's not clear if knight f6
if uh
if you can take but anyways even if
queen goes to d2 yeah it's not yeah
this is this is maybe not very good for
white but yeah normally
normally i think this is not yeah you
know there were some f5 ideas i mean
and then yeah i don't really
it's not i'm not completely sure if
if levon heaven confused the move
further because i have a feeling that
edcd was
uh yeah should have been played maybe
because now
g4 is a threat actually and i don't see
what black
it might be a quite uh uh
quite a mistake knight h5 i'm not
completely sure but it might be yeah
because
this is united h5 i think it feels to me
that
either he has something kind of
spectacular here which i
i don't immediately see or as vladimir
said now that the bishop is on e3
and the potential threat of queen h4
check can be very easily met by bishop
f2 which is
basically the point of the uh the point
of the move uh the threat of g4 followed
by something like knight g3 or knight f4
is
uh very very strong if you imagine black
making some kind of a waiting move like
i don't know a5 is a nonsense move just
to
put the position on the board g4 you
have to go back to f6 now
and white plays something like knight g3
yeah and why this is
yeah this is just a very very uh uh
unpleasant position because i think
black moralist never generates any kind
of counterplay on the king's side now
and uh white has a much uh
much safer position to to press his
spatial advantage so now of course
uh i think it's possible that levon have
just confused
the move order and now he needs to find
a justification of knight h5 which is uh
yeah maybe considering even moves like
f5 but i'm not quite sure it's going to
work yeah
f5 yeah sure there's a number of
questions because
yeah maybe you can still do this because
e6 is a serious question
i was i was six yeah yeah we take and
after yeah i want to fight
with the rook yes but that looks very
very
suspicious somehow it does yeah but
maybe we don't have anything better
anymore maybe we absolutely have to go
for it this is the big question though
yeah because uh even knight g3 is looks
i just really i was hoping maybe i can
play rookie five and pretend that's all
according yeah
yeah maybe maybe yeah yeah maybe you're
right knf2 but some
sacrifices are possible even for
compensation
i don't know yeah rook takes a five
maybe queen d2 is a good is a
move but then i don't know if you can
take on c4 after queen d2
uh probably not because knight g3
probably wins yeah
or even g4 i thought of maybe g7 simply
yeah so i don't know yeah that's f5 is a
is a dubious move it doesn't look great
but
the other other possible options
look even more gloomy so i
suspect he will try to to make yeah it's
quite an unfortunate beginning of the
game for levon because
yeah i mean it's pretty clear to me okay
we will ask him
at the press conference but pretty clear
to me that most likely he have just
forgotten his notes and forgotten to
include edcd before playing knight h5
so so uh let's maybe try to see the
the sharpest game so far which is duda
carlson
uh so what can i say it's beef i i'm
actually i'm thinking now b5 is a very
logical move of course trying to get
knight b6 bishop e6 etc
but uh i start to think okay
why not to try g4 here
i'm not quite sure if it's if it works
but it's quite an interesting try
g4
hg and maybe rook g1
because h3 there is g3 yeah maybe that
is a little too much here knight b6
h3 but yeah even gh probably
that is too much to play like this there
is some
so okay still bishop h7 check bishop f5
but
uh also instead of gh
maybe other moves are possible like g3
so that is maybe
too much yeah g4 so then
maybe white should be a little bit
more cautious yeah very interesting
maybe knight g3 is an interesting move
trying to attack the pawn on h5 i mean
in case of
if h4 knight f5 comes
and possibly after knight g3
maybe black will have to sacrifice this
pawn
or playing queen a5 uh trying knight b6
maybe queen a5
attacking the pawn on a2 uh if can be
one
which is not forced of course and maybe
knight b6 would come
and yeah black has bishop e6 he has his
own play also
uh so uh it's pretty
yeah i mean very interesting very very
sharp position
here b5 b5 so let's let's come back to
to the uh position in the game so what
are the options
maybe even d5 i i i think what about
trying to play d5
i mean just to break in the center and
to me it looks like a
very interesting move and actually quite
a dangerous move
um what what can black do
c5 of course would be logical but then
b5 pawn is hanging bishop takes b5 i
don't know if it will be enough
compensation for
for black like queen a5 maybe
uh but it's a healthy pawn after all
yeah queen a4 maybe is possible i don't
see
much compensation but otherwise d5
yeah because aft let's say if
c takes d5 then bishop h7 check looks to
be also bishop xb5 of course is
pretty good but bishop h7 check might be
a real problem
and kin probably f8 because h8 is even
more dangerous and rook takes d5
now and this doesn't look good at all
for
for black so this is to my understanding
d5
i don't know i don't know what let's uh
[Music]
let's try to see what is the plan after
d5 of course there is a
there is a maybe a sacrifice like
playing with the c5
first let's say bishop takes b5 rook
takes e3
and then trying to get knight fe 395
and the plane of the b line because
yeah it's interesting i would say
i don't know it doesn't look like it's
enough compensation but there is some
compensation even of more of a
positional nature uh trying to group
b8 and queen a5 maybe this is a plan
maybe this is a plan it's quite a
unusual way of playing i mean not
definitely not
magnus's style that's for sure but
maybe it is the best option and that's
that can be
uh actually the plan of magnus because
he must be probably still in his book so
to say yeah because h5 the position
after h5
is mr reticle and i guess long castle is
he played b5 rather quickly i mean
took him not such a long time so
probably
he is still in the book and d5 move is
rather obvious so i
i guess that might be his
his plan um
even most likely because i don't really
see any other
any other acceptable
ideas i mean after d5
so what else white can try to do because
yeah i guess otherwise knight b6 black
will just play knight b6 and then he
will have quite a serious initiative on
the white squares
bishop e6 knight d5 knight c4 so
i i don't know if b5 is a novelty was it
played or not but
uh
i think if not then probably because of
d5 yeah
because it it seems to me that if not d5
black will probably be doing pretty well
unless knight g3 but the problem of
knight g6 is that even when you take the
pawn on h5
the knight gets becomes you know very
passive on the on the edge of the board
and also even maybe knight b6 can be
possible
with the idea after knight takes h5 that
black has
bishop g4 uh so that is
uh also possible yeah so i i guess i
guess knight g3 is not so
so dangerous then again g4 hg
and after h3 fortunately for black he
has g3
even if maybe yeah that can be an option
g3 probably on rook dg1 now
just to try to open up the uh
g line somehow and to get
attack on g line that's maybe quite
interesting
uh you want to take with a knight on g3
and then
start direct attack on the
black skin black what does what can he
do
i would say gf is possible but quite
risky bishop takes f2 now the g
line is open and
even if there is no clear threat yet but
it
seems to be like a long-term initiative
uh
i would consider probably playing after
rook d g1
i would probably consider rook takes c3
again
the same sacrifice just trying to keep
the jeep on the life yeah fe to
actually to close the g line and now
let's say queen c7
that might be interesting because not so
easy uh it's not
to take back the g3 pawn
and otherwise black has definitely
certain compensation and he wants to go
knight d6
so i would expect queen d2 now probably
trying to play with the knight f4 with
the queen e1 to attack the opponent
on g3 and black might start uh
different things like c5 looks
interesting knight b6
uh very very sharp game ah i'm
probably i'm missing knight take g3 so
instead of queen d2
instead of 22 there is knight take g3
move and this
might be quite painful bishop takes g3
queen g2
and black's bishop cannot
move out because of mate on g7 and
otherwise uh white just takes back
the bishop so then in such situation
yeah so if this is true then maybe g4 is
a very very interesting move to play
of course black maybe he maybe magnus
just wants to play
h4 it looks uh
strange but who knows it might be okay
just to block the
uh the g line and again having in mind
very often rook takes c3 as a positional
uh sacrifice let's say if white is
continuing like rook dg1 let's say dg1
knight p6 let's say g5
and again i would consider as a serious
option rook takes e3
yeah because now fvfg and the
black king is pretty safe and actually
even he can start to push
after at some point g4 and so on so
maybe this is the
th for h4 because hg again after g4 hdg
looks pretty dubious i would say
i mean h3 yeah let's try h3 now i really
don't
like oh i mean letting the line
the h line open it's really dangerous so
g3
i would say it's so maybe only move
dg1 and now also
kg1 is possible by the way not clear
which rook has to be on g1 because the
other one might might be useful in the
center
so one of the rooks to g1
uh maybe actually i i would even say
rook
hg one maybe is even more logical i
would say okay g1 because
i don't think that i will need the h
line yeah so that's why
and sometimes white can get on the c5
bishop d7
so hg one and uh yeah that's very
interesting but anyway d5 was played in
the game
d5 was played so now let's see
let's see if magnus uh was it his
preparation
or or he just missed d5 but in any case
uh it seems to me that c5 and rookie
three is a
very interesting way of playing i
actually
kind of even like it for black i mean
[Music]
i think black can have quite a
significant compensation here and
especially i'm sure computer would say
white is better there but
in a practical game i don't know which
side
because black has a long-term initiative
quite easy play black squares
so let's see i mean my my
conclusion here is that uh if magnus
would uh
start thinking now yeah it would mean
that he just
uh let's say he is out of book and
basically he
misdefies or or
underestimated it if he will play
quickly that then it means he is
still in the book but in any case i
predict c5 bishop b5 will take c3
or c5 bishop b5 through b8 first
maybe still bishop c6 and
[Music]
at some point rook takes e3
and n95
something like that and i don't know
what is this position
i would say that yeah black has a lot of
initiative knight c4 queen a5
is coming so maybe it will be eight to
start with r8 instead of rook takes e3
yeah
so rook b8 of course it gives white an
opportunity to play bishop takes d7
but that might also be a very you know
bishop to ac7 it seems to me that black
has a bishop to
d7 and next queen a5 it looks very
dangerous for white i mean black has a
lot of
initiative here and otherwise after
b8 wherever bishop goes let's say c6
looks like a most logical square of
course black can try to manage without
the exchange sacrifice maybe trying to
play rookie seven followed by knight e5
or queen a5 bishop a6 there are
different
ways to do it but i
i really like rook takes c3 rook takes
e395
i really like this for black
and as we you remember uh if you
remember yeah yeah c5 was played quickly
so i'm pretty sure it is the magnus's
preparation still then
then it might be a difficult time for
for jan christoph here because if magnus
is still
[Music]
having this analyzed yeah it's
not not a great
[Music]
not a great not great news for him uh
for for a while
absolutely what would you say i'm back i
don't know
yes yes peter you are back we are very
happy uh i i apologize i apologize for
what happened uh
of this this generally doesn't happen
very much but seems like
like the entire internet died i'm i'm
currently connected from from my phone
which might
uh be a bit of an issue later but for
now uh
happy to rejoin the show and yeah this
is a very striking development d5 c5
bishop xb5
yeah i agree with your assessment uh i
think in particular against a
well-prepared opponent
it gets very scary for white these types
of positions because
uh he will have to he'll have to solve
very you know immediate problems after
the expected rook v8 yeah actually i
mean it's also that i
simply i simply like very much black's
position
even objectively not only that but
it subjectively looks what do you think
peter i mean
it looks very different can we try maybe
playing c4
yeah thinking about it c4 yes yes maybe
it is a better
uh option but still uh of course black
has
lots of uh ideas here yeah i i actually
like okay
rook takes e3 i really like this idea
yeah this first does look
very very uh thematic and uh
yeah because then a6 and if knight c3a6
c4 pawn is hanging
somehow and
it's so difficult to play with white
disposition yeah black has a lot of
initiative i don't even know what what
would be your move
uh here i i would be panicking here with
whitey i i
i'm not sure what i'm supposed to play
because the king side is now completely
secure for black which means that like
the entire game will happen on the queen
side it's a
uh it's a very comfortable situation yes
black had to give up quite a lot of
material but
uh yeah defending defending positions
like this is
is never fun maybe we can go for some
extremely passive ideas like bishop a4b3
trying not to lose anything
uh on on the queen side but it looks
scary
i would say maybe at least h3 first yeah
just
yeah because i don't like all sorts of
bishop g for knight g for ideas yeah
but yeah queen a5 and
bishop a6 and i don't know
it's not fun it's not fun yeah it's not
fun at all
i know i know which which side i would
like to play in this position
yeah yeah i think uh everyone who
chooses
black yeah yeah every professional
player because
yeah so it's uh yeah r8 is played yeah
yeah
so magnus says i've uh you remember
couple of days ago in our stream
judith has asked me who has the best
opening preparation
nowadays and i i put
magnus in the first place and i well
this game it proves it again yeah
because
it's a it's a real line not such a you
know
not very fashionable although people
start to play it
lately and even there magnus has a very
deep uh
preparation it seems yeah and absolutely
unnecessary i mean
all those moves which white played were
not definitely not forced
so this shows that that magnus or his
trainers and they made a very
very serious work even in this line yeah
yeah
a lot clearly a lot of thought goes into
playing even the sidelines these days
like
this is you know he has been doing this
consistently but still you would expect
you know the sicilian and the the
spanish to be
the main parts of his repertoire but
even these these sidelines are
are well analyzed and uh there is a lot
of interesting
original ideas everywhere yeah i saw
that quote from your conversation which
you did and uh
yeah it did not surprise me at all that
you uh that you put magnus
as uh as number one i was
a little bit more surprised about being
in european uh
opinion if i remember correctly you put
ding and bobby as numbers two and three
fabi two ding three yes yeah i
fight once again probably no surprise uh
thing i thought
was of the three people you chose was
maybe the only
non-obvious choice because you would
think that maybe there are
uh some people who are still ahead of
him but he has made a tremendous amount
of progress i agree i agree i mean
of course i would say that maybe any
shirt he is he can compete with dean and
maybe even overtake him
yeah in this but dean definitely also
has his his repertoire
is much more limited i mean he doesn't
play everything but what he plays
he usually knows really well very deeply
yeah
but it's true but magnus yeah it's his
preparation becomes
really impressive and uh considering the
fact that he is also the best player in
the world nowadays i mean that makes
that makes uh quite a good explanation
that gives a good explanation of his
superiority nowadays yeah because when
like
uh gary kasparov at his best yeah at his
best time
it was both yeah and when it's both it's
very difficult
yeah it's very difficult to play uh to
play against the player who
uh who gives you no odds in the opening
and then also outplays you from equal
positions
yeah uh it's a it's a it's a very hard
combination to counter for sure
so let's see let's see maybe the other
game i i have a feeling that
young crystal will take some time
here because he should yeah if he
doesn't
if he doesn't it's a mistake i would say
i think yeah i think if you if you don't
actually take a longish pause in a
position like this
you are probably not not approaching it
uh correctly yeah because i would i
would actually
uh just try to you know if i was white
here but maybe try to
maybe check bishop legislation bishop d7
knight g3 it looks dubious but at least
to try to get something very quickly you
know to
to get uh i i really don't like it and
probably doesn't work but
just somehow to get out of this
long-term positional
torture i mean initiative torture after
the rook takes a 395
but actually it's probably pretty bad as
well yeah bishop d7 bishop d7 the
problem is bishop f4 would have been
a good uh a good opportunity to change a
bishop but then rook takes
it too is a problem yeah that is a big
problem for
for hang on a second um yeah if if
white tries to change this bishop uh on
d6 trying to play bishop f4
then yes uh bishop f4 and rook takes it
too and then
i'm i'm having a check some kind of a
weird
weird interaction with the client where
i all i can do is draw arrows and
people who have seen me who have seen me
draw errors in the past will know that
uh i'm very bad with arrows but
maybe for some reason i can't actually
make moves
uh for the time being i'm i'm hoping
this will get
it will magically disappear because i
don't really want to draw errors for the
rest of the
for the rest of this i can imagine by
the end of our commentary you know
the screen will be kind of full blue
yeah it's it's it's going to be it's
going to be very very
surreal if it continues like this but i
yeah for now
for now yeah i can i can draw i'm very
good
it's now you you try to yes yeah yeah
we can remove the errors but we
excellent yeah but this still this still
draws errors i have no idea what's going
on i've never i've never encountered
this before
today is seemingly a day where everybody
regrets inviting me to the stream i
think
i'm going to i'm going to sort of
provide every single reason for people
to to regret inviting me
internet crashes weird weird bugs that
weren't there before until i came in and
actually i can try peter if uh yeah i
can try to
take control and to try to make moves
for the first time
but i don't know if i will do much
better than you
it's difficult it's difficult to do much
worse right now so so you think it's
let me try to to see if
if i can manage it
[Music]
yes for now not yes i think so yeah okay
let's
let's go bishop f4
no ah also also i have arrows so if
bishop f4 rook takes it to
yes okay uh bishop f4
rook taxi too uh
so peter is it is it you or me who is
who is now
uh moving the pieces i think nobody
nobody
is currently moving the pieces so let's
uh
let's okay bishop f4 okay yes
yes so c4 was played yeah that's uh
that's not a great sign yeah
i mean as you've just mentioned now
peter i would expect that black
should have probably
should have probably white should
probably
take some time here because c4 of course
it's a natural move but
uh i'm not quite sure if
if uh after rook takes e3 let's say
in particular yeah i would very much
like rook takes e3 to happen because i
think
uh it you know the the game becomes
particularly spectacular if he does that
but he has already played a6
uh yeah maybe he just wants to i don't
know he wants first a6 and then to take
on e3
but f6 uh i don't know if i can take on
d7 and knight c3
yeah exactly i would i would expect i
would expect uh young chester just to
jump at the opportunity to
trade that you know you know peter queen
a5
comes yeah it's a little before this
yeah very scary yeah
it's uh it doesn't really help it
doesn't really help quite
so much but yes i mean it's amazing to
stabilize like rook a1 i want to play
bishop d2 i want to play b3
and if i don't get mated in like three
moves maybe i'm alive
maybe you will because rook b4 let's
check
before i would like
[Music]
yeah that's a bit too much but uh i
thought
i thought you were going to i thought
you were going to take yeah three but a
b a b yeah that's yes
queen takes this three check queen c2 it
seems that uh
uh stabilizing yeah yeah so maybe that
is too much but of course black has
queen a5 let's say queen a5 looks very
logical yeah rook he won and let's look
for now
many many interesting moves yeah here
seemingly yeah lots i mean hp5 is maybe
the most obvious but yeah i do
i don't want to play bishop at least
yeah i want to play bishop d2 anyway
and what about maybe queen b4 b3 yeah
queen b4 b3
scary but might and rook takes b2 yeah i
mean i understand it
shouldn't work yeah let's let's take a
look at this is the most fun yeah this
is the most
fun let's see if i lose if i put the
king in the corner
bishop
[Music]
yeah i i need to play queen c1 and you
play wish p5 here i need to play
and you at least have rugby one check
but i don't know if you win
i don't actually win yeah because i can
take yes and then i
i even have rook takes c5 in the end
yeah and i think white comes out ahead
even which is not fair
that's true yeah uh that's true
yeah so maybe rook b2 but uh yeah of
course black has a very good position
anyway but i i would have taken on e3
first yeah
but actually how stupid is g6 here
g6 uh
i 94 is too dangerous yeah i don't like
i feel like
but maybe bishop d2 again bishop because
i have queen a4
yeah that was that was my problem that
you uh by playing bishop
five i give back the the a4 square for
the queen so it doesn't quite work
we need to kind of fine tune this
because it does feel if you look at this
position it does feel like black
absolutely has to have tremendous
compensation yeah
no definitely he has it's even more of a
question if
he can kind of win by force here yeah i
don't know if of course a move like
bishop takes h2 might be
working but uh
[Music]
i mean it's possible just to take back
the pawn maybe but that's
that's i mean yeah that's not the way
yeah we're kind of selling selling
ourselves a little bit short yeah
yeah if we started doing this yeah yeah
so i would i would definitely consider
something more
also i don't know if q5 was uh ah by the
way another question is why
why did we go rookie 1 maybe to start
with bishop d2 immediately
let's try that's maybe more
more solid we would yeah this is feels
like bishop d2 is probably the move we
can
never avoid making and rookie one is not
rookie one is more optional
mm-hmm still queen
if yeah queen before no q4 doesn't work
because of knight b5
even ib5 exists yeah which is very
important here
not so bad yeah that's somehow white uh
okay big bishop f4 after knight b5
then b8 is hanging yes so maybe not
maybe queen a5 is not the right way
to play okay yeah so what about the
stars then bishop g4 maybe is this idea
just try to
go to get queen d7 bishop f5 but that
doesn't look already so
i guess we go e1 right because when you
even can you
yeah said i i really not sure about
economics why it is paul now but also
him because there is no chance he can
and i was